let's talk about impeachment briefly
support for impeaching Donald Trump has
spiked 41% but I want to go through this
carefully because there are different
things that impeachment could mean as
you probably all know by now because
they keep mentioning it impeachment is
not the removal of the president
impeachment is the process whereby the
house says we believe the president
should be removed for these reasons and
we are filing articles of impeachment it
then is up to the Senate to vote to
convict and remove the president and
these are two different processes and a
lot of people are interchangeably using
the word impeachment to mean either
start an impeachment inquiry file
articles of impeachment in the house go
through the investigative process of
impeachment in the house and actually
vote to remove Trump in the Senate but
those are four different things okay
there's a new CNN poll conducted by SSRS
which says that 41% of the country now
wants Donald Trump impeached and removed
from office it's good that they're
asking the question in that way now this
is actually not the record high for
Donald Trump's presidency the same poll
back in September at 47% of the country
wanting Trump impeached in December 43%
of the country wanted Donald Trump
impeached and removed and it dropped
into the mid 30s and now it's back up to
41% the most important takeaway is that
this is a lot it's not normal that 41%
of the country wants the president to be
impeached and removed and not
surprisingly the recent rise in those
numbers is driven primarily by Democrats
and some centrist independents Democrats
now 76 percent support impeaching Donald
Trump that's up eight points from April
so this tells us a few important things
number one it's just not normal for more
than 40% of the country to believe the
president should be impeached even
during the hyper partisan insanity of
the Obama administration the highest
impeachment support ever for Barack
Obama was 33 percent even for Bill
Clinton who was impeached impeachment
support never surpassed 30 percent if I
recall correctly the current president
has 41 percent impeachment
removal support that is massive number
two support for impeachment especially
among Democrats and independents seems
to be correlated with the number of
prominent Democratic lawmakers who are
calling for impeachment proceedings now
we don't know for sure if national
support for impeachment is going up
because more prominent Democrats are
calling for impeachment I don't know if
more prominent Democrats are calling for
impeachment because they see that more
Americans are supporting it so I don't
know about which way the causation goes
if any but it's a trend that's rising in
parallel they're correlated at least
this is the most important thing to
understand here do not let the Trump
administration and right-wing media
trick you into believing that it's no
big deal that 41% of the country wants
Trump impeached impeachment of a
president of the United States has
happened only I believe three times in
the more than 240 years that the United
States has been a country that forty-one
percent support doing that is rare and I
believe that as more facts come out if
more Americans read the Moller report if
an impeachment inquiry starts which
Bernie Sanders is now calling for I'll
talk about that after the break the 41
percent number is going to go up and
what the Trump administration is going
to insist on is this is just partisan
nonsense
it's partisan bad angry Democrats once
you get to forty five percent forty
seven percent forty eight percent
mathematically it cannot be just
partisan Democrats so do not let them
trick you into thinking that this is no
big deal this is a big deal there have
been three impeachments in American
history I hope I'm getting that number
right and that more than forty percent
of the country wants that done to the
current president is a massive massive
deal will be posting a poll question
about this on the David Pakman show
Instagram page please follow us there at
David Pakman show and also please follow
me on Instagram at David Pakman I am
heading to Los Angeles after today's
program later in the show I will
announce why and I do believe it's the
type of trip where
you will want to be following me on
instagram at david pakman